l'année 2022 là c'est confirmé c'est
l'année la plus chaude jamais
enregistrée depuis qu'on fait des
relevés c'est-à-dire depuis 1900 donc
c'est quand même assez incroyable alors
que nous on a explosé tous les records
de chaleur parce qu'on peut parler de
chaleur quand même on avait 25 au pied
des Pyrénées hier en cette fin d'année
aux États-Unis alors ça a été on en a
parlé ça a été bizarre du siècle ce
journaliste est plus habitué au studio
et aux infos sportives mais il s'est
retrouvé envoyé sur le terrain pour
couvrir la situation météo on sent qu'il
a accepté à contrecœur
et je voulais vous montrer quelques
images parce que franchement c'est
hallucinant regardez on est au Canada
c'est près du lac le lac Érié qui est à
la jonction entre les États-Unis et le
Canada et là on se croirait dans un le
décor de dessin animé moi j'ai cherché
des vrais gens dedans parce que je me
suis dit que personne
en sucre d'orge enfin c'est complètement
dingue la Bretagne qu'on adore Myriam
Bretagne une région de France
pas suffisamment représenté et que
pardon excusez-moi vous êtes qui
exactement
alors si vous me connaissez pas c'est
normal je suis Ludovic béguin et je
viens du futur de 2025 d'ailleurs Myriam
est-ce que vous êtes en mesure de me
donner la météo du 3 janvier 2025 non
non pas vraiment non l'autre événement
majeur de ce 31 décembre se sont bien
sûr les vœux d'Emmanuel Macron qui
viennent de se terminer il y a 5 minutes
apparemment
19 minutes de discours c'est quasiment
le temps de toute une émission de
quotidien si on enlève les pubs Emmanuel
Macron il parle 19 minutes record battus
il balaye tout et tu retiens rien vous
pensez qu'il manque de courage je sais
pas je pense qu'il manque de courage oui
et c'est pourquoi je lui renouvelle
notre invitation monsieur Président on
vous dites pas de courage sur ce plateau
du côté de la majorité présidentielle
une voix se fait entendre
les premiers temps donner l'info aux
habitants le député renaissance des
Yvelines car le livre reprend une
chanson de Michel Delpech pour raconter
sa première année de débuter se
retourner ça me fait drôle d'être un
député mais ça fait rien je vais m'y
faire la politique continue
malgré tout bon c'est vrai que je suis
pas objectif car le livre je connais
depuis longtemps c'est un ancien
journaliste de Canal il était
journaliste de sport moi je l'aime
beaucoup je l'aime bien donc je suis pas
objectif mais je trouve que c'est réussi
aura-t-on des coupures d'électricité oui
aura-t-on des orientations du prix de
l'énergie oui allons-nous à nouveau
subir une vague de covid oui devra-t-on
travailler plus longtemps en 2023 oui
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il promet en janvier
chaud ça va chauffer en janvier à
tweeter le leader de la France insoumise
samedi les premières grèves devraient
tomber à partir de mi-janvier les
macronistes eux parient sur une certaine
finalement
l'attitude des Français une résignation
peut-être parce que finalement est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres choix que de
travailler plus longtemps pour sauver
notre système vous savez le président
Macron nous a exhorté à travailler plus
c'est pas trop l'humeur du moment alors
mais mais vous allez voir c'est une
tendance mondiale la semaine de quatre
jours l'humanité il croit 63 % les
Indiens ils croient alors ça c'est
surpris mais même vous avez 41% des
Français qui pensent que ça va se
généraliser un jour les gens fériés en
orange les pompes possibles si on se
concentre sur le mois de mai l'exemple
regardez quand même les ponts possibles
selon ce journal parce que le lundi au
weekend
[Rires]
tu ne travailles que huit jours au mois
de mai en posant bah voilà
de speed feignant qui veut plus rien
[ __ ] parce que
mais non mais un moment donné je me
contient mais tu vois c'est impossible
mais c'est impossible parce que en fait
par cascade l'éducation nationale
provoque la fermeture de certaines
entreprises tu as des entreprises qui
disent aujourd'hui bon bah c'est
tellement le bordel pour nos salariés on
ferme quoi et et je trouve qu'on est
dans la culture nature du moins faisant
c'est un hommage appuyé qui auront Omar
Sy au tirailleurs sénégalais dans les
colonnes du Parisien mais à l'occasion
d'une question sur la guerre en Ukraine
l'acteur en a profité pour interpeller
les Français sur leur perception des
guerres dans le monde comme j'ai de la
famille ailleurs en Afrique je sais
qu'il a toujours eu des enfants en
guerre des familles brisées ça veut dire
que quand c'est en Afrique vous êtes
moins atteint on vit pas dans le même
microcosme après moi
contre toi moi je les côtoie pas
regarde la production
puisse avoir l'idéologie qui puisse sur
les Terriens sénégalais c'est sur la
culture
ça sert à réformer l'idéologie des gens
tu vois regarde la production
[Musique]
je répète si c'est pour maintenant
régler les trucs fallait pas m'appeler
il a pas envie plus tard
tu peux te t'écraser c'est bon
d'où il est porte-parole des tirailleurs
sénégalais parce qu'il parce qu'il a il
a
une vérité historique je vois pas d'où
il vient à porte parole de tout le
continent africain et je suis d'accord
avec toi Olivier l'Ukraine le continent
africain s'en [ __ ] première définition
il a soutenu sa thèse
Valérie il a soutenu sa thèse non Damien
un trou duc je l'avais vu et j'ai pas
reçu
alors moi on me fait croire tout le
temps des choses mais c'est pas une
sorte d'être candide c'est qu'il se
passe tellement des trucs de dingue dans
le monde entier que en fait on peut
croire à tout donc je vois pas où est le
problème par exemple moi on m'a fait
croire qu'on allait faire venir Dalida
aujourd'hui
Dalida
c'est justement ce que je disais on
entend pas parler beaucoup d'elle elle
se fait discrète
c'est le problème